donc dans un salon tout neuf que les 11
jurés du prix goncourt en délibéré cette
année pour décerner le prix 87 je vous
propose d'entendre et bien le nom du
lauréat
il faut savoir également que ceux du
renaudot se sont réunis ben pas très
loin sur le même palier dans mad
restaurant alors le nom du goncourt
maintenant avec sylvie marion qui est
sur place le prix goncourt 1987 a été
attribué au 6e tour de scrutin à tahar
benjelloun pour la nuit sacrée par six
voix contre deux à guy hocquenghem pour
eve une à angelo rinaldi pour les roses
de pline et une eye adding pour le
sorgho rouge avait obtenu des voix au
tour précédent
christiane baroche marie cardinal
philippe le guillou marie nimier
nicholas audrey et denis tillinac
je vous remercie au second tour de
scrutin par six voix contre trois à
tahar benjelloun pour la nuit sacrée le
prix théophraste renaudot en 1987 a été
attribué à rené jean claud pour son
roman l'enfant
hallucinant